The next mesh optimization I want to talk about
is when and where to use Nanite.
Now, Nanite is Unreal Engine 5's new virtualized geometry
system, and it allows you to have
meshes that have triangle counts that
are in the millions.
In the screen in front of us, we see a static mesh
at the top and the same static mesh,
but this time utilizing the Nanite technology.
And if we take a look at the highlighted area,
we can really start to see where Nanite outperforms
traditional static meshes.
This area highlights a ridge and this wooden sign,
and the static mesh, the top, we see some polygonal geometry.
And this is typical of static meshes of this size.
This isn't a huge prop.
This is just a regular sign.
However, with the Nanite mesh, notice in that same area,
we don't really actually see any
of this typical polygonal geometry.
We actually see a fantastic silhouette
that even has dips and peaks in it,
much like we would expect if we were looking at an object
in the real world.
One question you also might be asking yourself is,
when should I use Nanite?
What if I am not using a static mesh
that has millions of triangles?
The answer to that question is whenever possible.
Nanite should be enabled on any and all static meshes
that you're utilizing.
The only reason you shouldn't be using Nanite
is if the platform you're currently developing for
doesn't support Nanite, or the object or effect
or item you're working on requires the use of something
that Nanite doesn't support,
such as skeletal mesh animations.
Now, you can enable Nanite on any static mesh
throughout a number of different locations
inside of Unreal Engine 5.
The first way to enable Nanite is on import.
When you import your static geometry on import,
there is an option to actually build
the corresponding Nanite mesh for that asset.
You can also enable and then set settings
for your Nanite meshes inside of the details panel
in your static mesh editor.
You can also use geometry collections
to enable or disable Nanite meshes.
And finally, you can enable and disable Nanite meshes
through the content browser
by selecting the required assets, right-clicking,
and then selecting Nanite,
and then the required Nanite option.
Well, Nanite is an amazing tool
that supports things like static meshes,
instance static meshes, hierarchical static meshes,
hierarchical instanced static meshes,
geometry collection, role position offset,
and spline mesh support.
It unfortunately doesn't support everything.
Things that are not currently supported
include skeletal animations, morph targets,
vertex painting on instances of Nanite meshes,
deferred decals, and custom UVs.
Now, with that said, the features that Nanite support
are always changing.
In fact, since its release back in Unreal Engine 5.0,
Nanite has actually added support
for both world position offset and spline mesh support.
So be on the lookout for new things
that Nanite can do in future releases of Unreal Engine 5.